do you put a stop on the intimacy of
y'all's relationship if you're heading
into a fight like do you fight
i hear that about fighters i've always
heard that about boxing and stuff they
say it takes your legs away or or
whatnot but dude i've
i've came and knocked people out and
i've not came and knocked people out too
so
i don't really believe in it damn damn
i wonder if i'd rather have a guy who's
already recently
ejaculated yeah knock me out or a guy
that's full of knock me out you know
yeah i guess they're all different yeah
yeah
i don't feel it i don't i don't believe
in the and it takes your legs away i
don't think you don't know
i don't think wow see that's never
really been a thing in your head where
you're like okay
when i was younger i used to i used to
you did yeah i'm just sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be
so far from my home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been